okay we now have I mean it's it's almost
useless to to put it in this in these
surprising terms we now have the
unsurprising confirmation that yes Paul
Manafort Donald Trump's former campaign
manager was involved in all sorts of
sketchy stuff with Russia there is now
an exclusive report from The Associated
Press it's been revealed that Trump's
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
had a plan to benefit the Putin
government and was being paid millions
of dollars per year to work for the
benefit of the Putin government around
the world manna fort proposed a
confidential strategy as early as June
2005 that he would influence politics
and business dealings and news coverage
inside the US and Europe and former
Soviet states to benefit the Putin
government even as US Russia relations
under then president george w bush were
growing worse manna fort had a ten
million dollar annual contract starting
in 2006 according to multiple interviews
with people familiar with the payments
to Manta Ford and according to business
records that The Associated Press has
obtained a quote from Paul Manafort in a
2005 memo to Oleg Deripaska we are now
of the belief that this model can
greatly benefit the Putin government if
employed at the correct levels with the
appropriate commitment to success the
effort quote will be offering a great
service that can refocus both internally
and externally the policies of the Putin
government mana Ford isn't denying these
revelations
he's just arguing there's nothing
nefarious here at all which may be true
in principle except for the reality that
this is the guy who was Donald Trump's
campaign manager for a while until there
was too much heat based on the
russia-ukraine stuff that he was wrapped
up in and he had to resign in shame and
there happened to be multiple
investigations into Trump collusion with
Russia the specifics of what manna fort
was doing may not in and of themselves
be nefarious but again millions of
dollars to promote Russia - the guy who
ran Trump's campaign and these
connections took place up to a deck
before he jumped on Trump's campaign
right so at this point we don't know for
sure that he was conflicted by the time
he signed on to the Trump tea tour but I
mean look at the Republican National
Convention they had a platform there the
one thing that the Trump team wanted to
get off of that platform was that they
were going to support Ukrainian missiles
or weapons to fight against Russia that
was the one thing that they took issue
with right over the connection there
right around the time when manna fort
had to resign because the heat just got
too too hot with regard to his
connections to Russia was when the
Republican National Committee met to
talk about what is going to be their
platform you've got the Trump apparatus
he's he's on his way to rather he's on
his way to the official nomination had
already unofficially secured it during
the Republican primary
they basically fine with everything in
the Republican platform except except
the one bit of influence the Trump camp
wants on the Republican platform is to
soften the language against Russia
stunning the problem also in terms of
figuring out whether this is or isn't
nefarious is that it contradicts the the
realization that manna fort was
receiving millions of dollars from
Russia contradicts prior statements from
Trump's administration and from manna
fort himself both of whom previously
said oh man afford never worked for
Russian interests so again even if the
specifics are not nefarious why lie and
this applies to Michael Flynn this
applies to Jeffrey Sessions and it
absolutely applies it absolutely applies
more than to anyone else you could argue
at this point based on what's known to
Paul Manafort
of course the real crime here if you ask
Republicans is who leaked this accurate
information to The Associated Press
that's all Republicans want to look at
on this pad and it's funny to see Sean
Spicer and the Trump administration
tried to distance themselves now from
Paul Manafort
yeah as if he didn't play a major role
in Trump's campaign he was a campaign
manager for March to April that's or
March to August that's a crucial time
yeah I it was either earlier this week
or maybe late last week where Sean
Spicer started sort of like a paul who
type of campaign where whenever Paul man
affords name would be brought up he
would
the approach of you know Paul Manafort
who was that guy again Oh yep all right
very minor figure during the entire
campaign and that made me think there
must be something big coming about Paul
man afford if they're completely
inaccurately saying yeah he wasn't
really a player in our campaign and
indeed days later this bombshell from
The Associated Press comes out that he
was on a ten million a year contract
pretty soon they'll forget who Michael
Flynn was raised national security and a
minor role in national security I mean
yes he was officially the national
security adviser but you know it's not
like Trump was calling him at 3:00 a.m.
for questions about national security he
was calling him at 3:00 a.m. for
questions about the currency value of
the United States dollar meanwhile
Donald Trump's administration is the
subject of an FBI investigation into
possible collusion with Russia
we've got Trump's national security
adviser Michael Flynn resigns in shame
after lying about his conversations with
Russian officials revealed to have been
a foreign agent lobbying for Turkey Jeff
Sessions Trump's attorney general lied
about meetings with Russian officials we
still don't even know what the bottom
line is there it's bad and then a trump
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
is a seemingly illegal unregistered
foreign agent of the Russian government
who is trying to influence US policy we
have moved from smoke to fire here
haven't we isn't it fair to say that at
this point I would think so especially
with ranking membership on the House
Intelligence Committee saying that there
is evidence direct evidence that Russia
and the Trump team colluded more than
circumstantial and circumstantial is
enough to trigger an investigation but
Adam Schiff now saying more than
circumstantial